All of the work we've been
doing so far with line
integrals has been with
scalar functions or
scalar-valued functions.
And when I say that, that just
means you give me an x and a y
and you evaluate the function
at that x and y, and you
get another scalar value.
You get just a number.
You don't get a vector.
So what I want to do in this
video is start to get ourselves
warmed up with regards to
vectors so that we can
understand what it means to
take a line integral with
vector-valued functions.
So let me write down some
Actually, even a better place
to start, let me draw a curve
or let me describe a curve.
So let's put that little
f of x, y to the side.
We can ignore it for now.
Let's say I have some curve c
and it's described, it can be
parameterized-- I can't say
that word-- as let's say, x is
equal to x of t, y is equal
to some function y of t.
And let's say that this is
valid for t is between a and b.
So t is greater than or
equal to a and then,
less than or equal to b.
So if I were to just draw
this on-- let me see-- I
could draw it like this.
I'm staying very
abstract right now.
This is not a very
specific example.
This is the x-axis.
This is the y-axis.
My curve-- let's say this
is when t is equal to a.
And then the curve might
do something like this.
I don't know what it does.
Let's say it's over there.
This is t is equal to b.
This actual point right
here will be x of b.
That would be the x-coordinate.
You evaluate this function
at b and y of b.
And this is, of course,
when t is equal to a.
The actual coordinate in r2 on
the Cartesian coordinates will
be x of a, which is
this right here.
And then, y of a, which
is that right there.
And we've seen that before.
That's just a standard way
of describing a parametric
equation or curve using
2 parametric equations.
What I want to do now is
describe this same exact curve
using a vector-valued function.
So if I define a vector-valued
function-- and if you don't
remember what those are, we'll
have a little bit
of review here.
Let me say I have a
vector-valued function, r,
and I'll put a little
vector arrow on top of it.
And a lot of textbooks, they'll
just bold it and they'll
leave scalar-valued
functions unbolded.
But it's hard to draw bold,
so I'll put a little
vector on top.
And let's say that r
is a function of t.
And these are going to
be position vectors.
And I'm specifying that
because, in general, when
someone talks about a vector,
this vector and this vector
are considered equivalent.
As long as they have the same
magnitude and direction, no one
really cares about what their
start and end points are as
long as their direction's
the same and their
length is the same.
But when you talk about
position vectors you're saying
no, these vectors are all going
to start at 0, at the origin.
And when you say it's a
position vector, you're
implicitly saying this is
specifying a unique position.
In this case, it's going
to be in two-dimensional
space, but it could be in
three-dimensional space.
Or really, even four, five,
whatever-- n dimensional space.
So when you say it's a position
vector, you're literally
saying, OK, this vector
literally specifies
that point in space.
So let's see if we can describe
this curve as a position
vector-valued function.
So we could say r of t.
Let me switch back
to that pink color.
This can stay in green.
Is equal to x of t times the
unit vector in the x direction.
The unit vector gets a little
caret on top-- a little hat.
That's like the arrow for it.
That just says it's
a unit vector.
Plus y of t times j.
If I was dealing with a curve
in three dimensions I would
have plus z of t times k.
But we're dealing with two
dimensions right here.
And so the way this works is
you're just taking your-- well,
for any t and still, we're
going to have t is greater
than or equal to a and then,
less than or equal to b.
And this is the exact
same thing as that.
Let me just redraw it.
So let me draw our coordinates.
Our coordinates right
here, our axes.
So that's the y-axis and
this is the x-axis.
So when you evaluate r of a,
that's our starting point.
So let me do that.
So r of a-- maybe I'll
do it right over here.
Our position vector-valued
function evaluated at t is
equal to a, is going to be
equal to x of a times our unit
vector in the x direction.
Plus y of a times our unit
vector in the vertical
direction, or in
the y direction.
And what's that
going to look like?
Well, x of a is this thing
right here, so it's x of
a times a unit vector.
You know, maybe the unit
vector is this long.
It has length 1, so now we're
just going to have a length
of x of a in that direction.
And then, same thing in y of a.
It's going to be y of a
length in that direction.
But the bottom line, this
vector right here-- if you add
these scaled values of these
two unit vectors, you're going
to get r of a looking
something like this.
it's going to be a vector that
looks something like that.
Just like that.
It's a position vector.
That's why we're nailing it
at the origin, but drawing
it in standard position.
And that right there is r of a.
Now what happens if a
increases a little bit?
What is r of a plus
a little bit?
And I don't know, we could
call that r of a plus
delta or r of a plus h.
I'll do it in a
different color.
Let's say we increase a
a little bit. r of a
plus some small h.
Well, that's just going to
be x of a plus h times
a unit vector i.
Plus y times a plus h
times the unit vector j.
And what's that
going to look like?
Well, we're going to go
a little bit further
down the curve.
That's like saying the
coordinate x of a plus
h and y plus a plus h.
I might be that
point right there.
So it'll be a new unit vector.
Sorry, it'll be a new
vector-- position vector--
not a unit vector.
These don't necessarily
have length 1.
That might be right here.
Let me do that same
color as this.
So it might be just like that.
So that right here
is r of a plus h.
So you see, as you keep
increasing you value of t until
you get to b, these position
vectors-- we're going to keep
specifying points
along this curve.
So the curve-- let me draw the
curve in a different color.
The curve looks
something like this.
It's meant to look exactly like
the curve that I have up here.
And for example, r of b
is going to be a vector
that looks like this.
It's going to be a vector
that looks like that.
I want to draw it
relatively straight.
That vector right
there is r of b.
So hopefully you realize that,
look, these position vectors
really are specifying the same
points on this curve as this
original, I guess, straight
up parameterization that
we did for this curve.
And I just wanted to that as a
little bit of review because
we're now going to break in
into the idea of actually
taking a derivative of this
vector-valued function.
And I'll do that in
the next video.